it's all along the ceiling here in the
living room and the windows it's
actually down in the corner
the mold is everywhere and Leticia
Banton says she and her three children
now all sleep in this damp living room
because the damp is worse in the bedroom
and two of her children she says have
respiratory health problems caused by
the mold on the walls of her Council
flat in South London Kion actually has
it the worst he was born in this flat I
didn't realize that the mold had
actually penetrated through the mattress
and their pillows their covers when I
put him to bed he was literally gasping
for air
um
so I had to call 111 they sent an
ambulance straight away and the nurse
confirmed that he has respiratory issues
and that the mold can exacerbate that
like in the tragic case of two-year-old
awab despite doctors notes warning of
the risks Wandsworth council has
declined leticia's requests to be moved
instead offering a new ventilation
system and mold wash they say they're
committed to helping but haven't been
given access to the property but
Charities say across the UK thousands of
families are living like this there are
a huge number of social housing
properties that are in a state that
isn't basically livable so this
absolutely awful tragic case is
um a sign really of I think what we all
know which is that for a significant
amount of time there simply has not been
enough investment the coroner in awab's
case said this is a defining moment in
the UK housing sector and the common
themes here are not just the poor
condition of people's homes but also the
fact that families concerns are
repeatedly being ignored and in a word's
case the housing secretary is in no
doubt where he believes the blame lies
it is a basic responsibility of the
local Authority but in particular the
Housing Association to make sure that
people are in decent homes and all this
what a battery all this oh if only we
had more government money do your job
man the chief executive of this
organization was responsible he was
warned his organization was warned
the problem is the warning lights are
blinking everywhere and with a shortage
of social housing councils say they
don't have the luxury of options
Jason Farrell Sky News